президент порошенко ласкаво просимо в
зону конфлікту доброго вечора доброго вечора ви сказали
що війна закінчиться коли буде звільнено останній
клаптик європейської української землі
чи ви мали на увазі Крим звичайно
він не повернеться до вас той чарівник
це не я повернувся
давай  ситуація в Криму повна,
наші покази, що анексія
суверенної української території є
брутальним порушенням міжнародного
права і не має виправдання, давай, у нас є
багато прикладів, коли
територія була окупована десятки років, але
наприкінці  день, коли міжнародний
правопорядок має бути відновлено, отже, за яких
обставин слід покарати,
але це дуже важлива деталь,
що ми плануємо зробити це
лише дипломатичними
засобами дипломатичним впливом гірчиці, і
це було б важкою роботою, тому що
якби  рівень життя в Україні
був би набагато вищим, ніж у Криму,
якби свобода преси свобода ЗМІ
свобода людей була б високою, якби це
буде європейською нацією з
безвізовим режимом з вільною
свободою бізнесу і всім
просто кримчани хочуть бути українцями пан.
президенте, одна справа, чого ти хочеш
, одна справа навіть, чого
хочуть жителі Криму, але це реальний світ, я
маю на увазі, що ти не можеш взяти Крим силою,
і росіяни не збираються його тобі
повертати, це було б як зобов'язання
самогубство для Путіна, щоб повернути це вам,
ви знаєте, що я знаю, що
решта світу знає, що це не
повернеться до вас,
чи не було б добріше сказати людям,
подивіться, я ненавиджу ідею оскаржувати вашу команду,
але в цілому  світ розуміє, що
це незаконна анексія, і весь
світ, увесь світ, понад 170
країн не визнають цю анексію
і обіцяють ніколи не визнавати,
але вони прийняли, якщо прийняли,
ні, вони не визнають, але вони  ми
прийняли ні ніхто з Європейського
Союзу не погодився з тим, що у нас немає боротьби з
Кримом у нас немає ніяких справ з Кримом у
нас немає дипломатичних відносин немає
радника - нічого в Криму у нас
обмежена зона та нульові інвестиції
- Крим у нас є така позиція  n
неприйняття, навіть не
визнання, і якщо ми це приймемо і
визнаємо, це означає, що це буде
повне порушення і зруйнує глобальну
систему безпеки, що буде
стимулюванням агресора, що
буде точно таким же, як у 1938 році
і я  просто не можу уявити, щоб хтось
у 1938 році запитав, чи розумієте ви, що
австрійці назавжди залишаться містером Німеччини,
оскільки моя відповідь була б ні, я розумію,
що пан.  Президенте, ви дивитесь на
окупацію Західного берега і
територій Ізраїлем через п’ятдесят
років, жоден член
Європейського Союзу не визнає, що це
все, крім незаконного, що наближається до
п’ятдесяти років, і всі визнали, що
це буде саме  те ж саме з
Кримом ні, тому що з нами правда,
з нами світ ні, ні, у нас зовсім
інша ситуація, і так,
адреси повністю ізольовані, але реальність така,
що росіяни фактично
встановили для вас обмеження, як вони не
знають, що вони  хотів зробити,
не буде повноправного членства в
ЄС і не буде повноправного
членства в НАТО, тому що європейці ніколи
не ризикнуть зробити це, вони будуть
об’єднуватися через російський російський біль
вже величезна ціна за брутальне порушення
та  ця величезна ціна - це санкція, ця
величезна ціна - це ситуація в економіці,
ця величезна ціна - це ситуація з
валютним резервом зброї,
величезна ціна з субсидією, яку він повинен
віддати Криму, і це не може тривати
вічно,
і давайте будемо реалістами, це, звичайно,
Росія є могутньою державою, але
якщо світ прийме агресію, вони
ніколи не будуть колишніми, тому що
це вони просто символізували глобальну
систему безпеки, яка була  створена
після Другої світової війни не працює, як ви
думаєте, Україна коли-небудь приєднається до НАТО так
, так, так, тому що не в ній, не в
них найближчі Німеччина вже
заявила, що не бачить членства зараз, як
сказав міністр Штайнмаєр минулого листопада, я
бачу  партнерство між Україною та
НАТО, але не членство саме
тому, що ми повинні відповідати критеріям
НАТО, а не відбулося сьогодні чи
завтра в 2008 році, а також чому,
тому що Росія заперечувала ні, тому
що Росія буде заперечувати проти нього в
2008 році на саміті  у Бухаресті це
було сприйнято всупереч, це була
заява, що двері відкриті для грузин
для України, але, оскільки Україна
не відповідає критеріям, ні, тому що я щойно
сказав, що  Добре, прем'єр-міністр Франції сказав
тоді, що ми проти
вступу Грузії та України, тому що ми вважаємо,
що це не є хорошою відповіддю на
баланс сил у вас, я дуже радий
знати вашу думку щодо
президента Франції, якщо  ви дозволите мені -
п'ять хвилин - вибачте, але якщо ви дозволите
мені згадати мою думку, тому ми є
суверенною незалежною державою, і ми
не питаємо дозволу ні
в кого іншого, ні з нашої причини, наша позиція
полягає в тому, щоб реформувати мою країну, і нам потрібно
що принаймні шість сім років, щоб
відповідати критеріям, ми повинні виконати роботу, яка
є необхідною для нас, і лише тоді ми
повинні запитати український народ і
провести референдум, чи приймає український народ
і хоче бути рідною
державою-членом через сім років  ти все ще
вручав тут
правильно і ти все ще маєш це правильно
це ситуація з двох сторін і
які основні зміни це відбулося
ти не протримався два роки два роки тому
ми маємо рівень підтримки НАТО
я  Інтеграція Членство в НАТО в
Україні Народ України шістнадцять відсотків один шість
сьогодні ми маємо підтримку
інтеграції в НАТО для шістдесяти відсотків шість нуль
ви розумієте, що українці, ви накладаєте
ставлення Заходу, вони ніколи більше не
відновлять лідерів, ви живете в
сучасному світі, можете уявити, що сталося
в  через шість сім вісім років світ
був би зовсім іншим, і
національна сьогодні є єдиною ефективною
системою безпеки, тому що всі інші
системи зруйновані російською окупацією
та агресією як в Україні, так і в Сирії,
і, можливо, в статусі будь-якої іншої країни
в тій ситуації, яка  повинні
довести нашим партнерам, що світ
був би безпечнішим, якби Україна мала
можливість це зробити,
для нас це морква, це світло в
кінці тунелю, яке спонукає нас
реформувати країну, і тепер вона повинна  не
бути документами ручки, я вже сказав ні,
і його членство цього не
станеться, сприяючи тому, що Штайнмаєр прояснив свою
позицію  Вибачте, це не німецька мова,
це просто позиція Штайнмаєра
на 2015 рік, і ніхто не знає, якою
буде позиція Німеччини в
2050 році, - пан.  Президенте, ви кажете, що
маєте письмо, ви кажете, що боретеся з
цим конфліктом за Європу, протистоячи
агресії, але чи не
розглядали ви можливість того, що Європі потрібна Росія
більше, ніж ви їй, їй потрібно було,
щоб Росія уклала угоду з Іраном щодо
ядерної проблеми?  Росія, щоб отримати
угоду щодо Сирії, потребує Росії для
боротьби з Ісламською державою, можливо,
їй потрібна Росія більше, ніж ви, ви
пропонуєте, щоб ми, Європа, ставилися до України, я
не пропоную, мені цікаво, справді, ви
розглядали можливість, що таке U
of A вони  «Більше про команду, яка захищає
Росію, ніж про задоволення, це дуже
гарне запитання,
тому що що таке Європейський Союз, це
28 членів, він визначає, що об’єднана Європа,
грошовий ринок,
Росія, безпека, ні, ви знаєте, що
цінує об’єднана Європа, і чому я
абсолютно впевнений  єдність Європейського
Союзу та солідарність з Україною,
тому що це не питання
початку, це питання цінностей,
і те, що зберегти це, не виглядає таким
єдиним сьогодні  з Європейським Союзом він робить
це ні не над питанням мігрантів ні не
над Грецією наприкінці дня і
щодо України, і щодо Греції, і я
дуже сподіваюся, що щодо кризи мігрантів
Європа об’єднається на
початку року  У 2014 році я зустрічався з більшістю
міністрів у справах Європейського Союзу
і запитав, чи буде це агресією,
чи можливо, що Європейський Союз може зберегти
Єдиність і запровадити санкції, знаєте,
яка була відповідь Ні, ніколи
Європейський Союз не може мати  консенсусне
голосування щодо санкцій, і я сказав ні, через
три місяці це сталося, тому, будь ласка,
давайте не закінчувати, як сітка, давайте
недооцінюємо Європейський Союз, давайте
спочатку подивимося на Мінську угоду, тому що
вона виглядає дуже крихкою за останні
кілька днів, маючи кілька місяців
Спокійно ми бачили бої
знову спалахують ми бачили
обстріли Організація з безпеки та
співробітництва в Європі повідомляла
про низку порушень припинення чи
буде це припинення  вогонь
загалом або ці порушення збираються
збільшити це не працює Мінськ це ні
це не працює ні подивіться у нас дуже
серйозна суперечка - я намагаюся бути
ммм говорю з досить великими аргументами
що це означає означає конгруентність
це просто  мирний план нічого не може бути,
ніхто не може бути проти засобів, тому що
засоби — це звичка до припинення вогню,
маленька зброя, звільнення всіх заручників,
негайний доступ для інспектора ЄК на будь-яку
територію чи в будь-яке місце, де
зберігається зброя, гуманітарна діяльність для
покращення гуманітарної кризи соціальної
і економічний розвиток
території та політична частина,
де ми маємо вільні та чесні вибори,
щоб дозволити людям, які живуть у Донецьку
та Луганську, обирати своїх
представників, щоб це всунули
наступного року з вашого дозволу одну річ, яку
ми часто знаємо з  Ваш дозвіл,
це не я пропустив термін,
тому що Україна зараз є дуже відповідальною
державою і дуже відповідальною частиною Мінських
угод  ми робимо все, що
обіцяли, ось чому ви всі
ракетники, якщо ви все ще перебуваєте на
території, на якій вони не повинні бути зараз
тут, у листопаді, як цитувала
Організація з безпеки та
співробітництва в Європі два дні тому
ні так ні тому що вони  зафіксуйте, вони
повідомили про це, не захоплюйте запуски ракет, ні
ваші, ні, тому що наша позиція
абсолютно зрозуміла, ми повністю
співпрацюємо з OSE, ми абсолютно
відкриті для всіх перевірок, тому що
ні, я маю, вони кажуть, чому я сказав, що ви
раді, що ракетна установка добре  у місці
не повинно бути добре, Тіме, вибачте, я відчуваю себе самотнім,
будь ласка, у нас є довгий список
звітів, і я відповідально роблю
заяву, що ми повністю реалізували всі
дрібні деталі із засобів, включаючи
зняття коштів, тому звіт
неправильний, ви кажете  ми не знаємо, ми у
нас немає поодиноких випадків невиконання
мінських угод, і вони отримали красу,
будь ласка,
я думаю, що ви обидва не можете бути праві, ОБСЄ,
і ви не можете бути праві, будь ласка
якщо ви дасте мені одну хвилину,
дякую, ми відповідаємо за частину
Мінських угод, вони повністю
співпрацюють з OSC, якщо взяти
номер звіту з української сторони,
а з російської сторони
це ще 1215 випадків, коли Росія
порушила обстріл  коли Росія
не допускає перевищення інспектора
як на кордоні, так і на території,
коли вони зберігають зброю, і у нас
трапився один випадок, але це було
негайно видалено через 40 хвилин, коли
інспектор прийшов, ми даємо їм це було
50  500 метрів від 23 кілометрів,
коли вони знаходять місце, і ми
негайно звільняємо та видаляємо його,
це шлях для автомобіля, ми співпрацюємо з OEC,
і це означає, що коли інспектору OEC
не просто не дозволили увійти, а
просто відкрили вогонь по нас  зверніться до
інспекторів, добре, тож у вас є
інше тлумачення, ні, це
від ОС, ні, ні, у нас інша
ситуація, тому що ми повністю виконуємо
Мінську угоду, це підтверджено ми
бачимо і  добре, це було два дні тому,
на жаль, ми маємо
рамки нашого спілкування, але я даю вам
хвилину після їхньої поразки, добре,
я покажу це глядачам, тому що
це дуже небезпечні речі, тому що
це російський сценарій для демонстрації  гаразд,
ні, ні, ні, обидва сайти порушили
мінську угоду, це неправда, тому що українці
повністю виконують все правильно, тоді
ви говорите, що так правдиво, дозвольте мені поговорити про
деякі обіцянки, які ви дали
відтоді, як стали президентом, одна з них
була  для боротьби з корупцією трохи більше
місяця тому посол США в Україні
звинуватив вашу генеральну прокуратуру
у вкрай незвичайному втручанні у
перешкоджанні зусиллям по боротьбі з корупцією
та захисті власних співробітників від
розслідування, чому
генеральний прокурор досі перебуває у своєму
офісі, якщо він це те, що він робить
чому і якщо ви серйозно ставитеся до
боротьби з корупцією, чому ви
дозволяєте цій ситуації тривати, це
починається з двох речей, перш за
все  але після цього ми розпочали
розслідування, незалежне розслідування
у співпраці з нашими
американськими партнерами, незалежну загальну
перевірку всередині генеральної прокуратури, яка
розпочала розслідування, і,
на жаль, але я сподіваюся, чи отримаємо ми
будь-які факти корупції, і якщо ці
факти підтвердяться, ніхто  одна
хвилина будь-хто, кого б звинуватили і
підтвердили, залишиться на посаді
розчарувати номер один пункт номер два
ми хочемо створити абсолютно ефективну
систему боротьби з корупцією
ми створюємо нове антикорупційне бюро
з абсолютно високим рівнем довіри
до абсолютно прозорої процедури  тверда
точка в новій особі, і вона буде
запущена 1 грудня
, ми призначимо зараз операцію від
делегації Союзу в Україні написали про
своє занепокоєння щодо деяких людей,
які були поставлені на цей новий
антикорупційний точно і нагадали вам
що допомога ЄС дуже велика, як вони
сказали у своєму листі до  ви
обумовлюєте зусилля українських партнерів
у боротьбі з ростом, і
вони повинні вас попередити, і вже наступного
дня ми вилучаємо цю людину з
відбіркової комісії та призначили тих,
кого запропонував Європейський Союз, у
тому числі я сподіваюся, що парламент
завтра голосуватиме пан.  Каслер,
який представлятиме Європейський Союз,
тому наша реакція дуже швидка та дуже
ефективна, незважаючи на те, що
найважливіше – це просто запустити нову
антикорупційну структуру, нову
антикорупційну систему негайно
з 1 грудня, і
найголовніше  що ця система
повинна мати довіру для мене навчання
людей
granion органи влади наші європейські та
американські партнери Mr.  президент, ти
хочеш показати, що світ, який ти привносиш
у нову еру, ти хочеш продемонструвати відкритість,
ти хочеш показати
парі подивіться, навіщо президенту потрібен
і отримує багато критики, навіщо
вам власна телевізійна станція канал
чому, коли  ОБСЄ каже, що високопосадовець зі
свободи ЗМІ каже пан.  Порошенко повинен
продати свою телестанцію, я твердо переконаний,
що обрані політики не повинні володіти
та контролювати ЗМІ, і навіщо це вам
, це дуже гарне запитання.
У 2003 році, коли я був опозиційним
політиком, я створив перше вільне
українське ЗМІ, яке  у нас були
абсолютно публічні та прозорі
відносини між журналістами та
власником, і це був перший приклад, який
завжди
вибачте за можливий, але ви обіцяли
бути іншим ні, я ніколи ні, я ніколи не
обіцяв продати п’ятий канал, ні,
але ви обіцяли бути іншим для
олігархи, які володіли нашими ЗМІ в цій
країні, я інший, і якщо ви
бачите п’ятий канал, можливо, один із
найбільш каналів, який найбільше
критикують і один із найбільш вільних, це
п’ятий канал, це дуже авторитетний
журналіст, і чому  чи потрібно тобі
навіщо дивись інші президенти мають
телеканал я в європі ми маємо дивись
я гарант свободи преси
і стандарту журналістів  st
Я 5-й канал, не маю жодних
заперечень або будь-якої критики, критики
за це також є проблема, що ви
обіцяли продати вам шоколадний
бізнес, але ви цього не зробили Російська
ви пообіцяли більше реклами Я обіцяю, тому
що тому що частина  мого бізнесу в Росії
було конфісковано Путіним і частина мого
бізнесу арештована і
неможливо продати арештований бізнес
тому що ви втрачаєте гроші ні тому що він
арештований саме зараз ми
вже там підписали
трастову угоду з одним з
найавторитетніших європейських трастів  і перекладіть
на абсолютне незалежне управління,
це спосіб, яким я не вирішу
це питання, у вас ще є кілька
візитів, ви обіцяли позбутися його
більшість із нього, ви можете вам може не сподобатися
моя відповідь, але я єдиний українець
президента, який прозоро
перераховує кошти до незалежного трастового фонду
з авторитетним ім’ям, і я думаю, що
це дуже європейський шлях у їхній країні
в стані страху, але ніхто не хоче, щоб  o
купити бізнес – це окремий
бізнес і політика, які
ви також обіцяли позбутися кишенькових
армій, як ви їх назвали, правий сектор,
група так званих добровольчих
батальйонів, правий сектор все ще існує,
і влади олігархів, як ви сказали,
більше не буде  олігархи в
Україні, олігархи все ще існують, вони
мають владу, яку вони використовували,
дуже вільно виглядаючи серед населення мої
обіцянки Я не обіцяю знищити
правий сектор, це політична партія,
але я обіцяю Румі перемістити її з
цього також не  тільки можна
закінчити, сер, так, будь ласка, я обіцяю
до звуку і вивести його з
фронту немає жодного
представника правого сектору
на передовій, а поліція це
відповідальність, до речі,
поліція відомого президента  доручити виявляти
будь-які незаконні збройні формування, незалежно від того
, чи вони належать до оолаг чи до
політичного угруповання незаконної армії, і якщо ви ставите
мету як олег, наша армія не
rmed, і я борюся з цим,
і ситуація, правий сектор,
це процес роззброєння, і
це нелегка робота, особливо
в країні, ми вже бачили
перестрілку між ними та поліцією
на Заході, це було так  було кілька місяців
тому, і деякі виводять це озброєні ополченці
з автоматами оточують
питання середня повага поставив мені запитання,
і я намагаюся повернутися до вас, коли ви сказали
це, що це був конфлікт між
правим сектором і поліцією, відразу
це було  військова операція до
лосося і правого сектора відразу
коли правий сектор намагався
спровокувати нацгвардію у нас армійська
операція я намагаюся ще раз вам пояснити
і президент країни
в стані війни де у нас
багато зброї  і ми намагаємося докласти
ефективних зусиль для роззброєння, щоб створити
закон і порядок, і гарним доказом
цього є те, що всі війська з
українського боку на території дотику дотримуються
режиму припинення вогню та дотримуються закону  d наказ
головнокомандувача українських військ,
але є доступні є
достовірні звинувачення у порушеннях прав
людини з боку міжнародної спільноти як
проти ваших військ, так і проти
іншої сторони, а також чи будуть вони
розслідуватися в першу чергу ні, оскільки ми
маємо  зовсім інший розмір цього
порушення і всі порушення від
українських розмірів належним чином розслідуються
з присутністю міжнародного
інспектора і всі речі з цієї
частини цієї частини кордону немає
і в цьому наша відмінність ми
цивілізовані європейські держави які  дотримуються своїх
обіцянок і своїх бандитів і
терористів, і якщо ви запросите вас
поїхати туди і отримати докази
своїми очима, що за
словами міжнародної спільноти, обидві сторони вчинили будь-який злочин,
але співчували протилежній,
якщо ви бачите статистику, як  багато
злочинців в українській армії було притягнуто
до слідства та відповідальності,
що було б найкращою відповіддю на
більшість  ernational давайте будемо об'єктивними і
так само не було абсолютно ніякої
реакції з боку терористів і бандитів
з їхнього боку це 8000 убитих
українців з будь-якою відповідальністю
з їхнього боку це 2000
мозкових військ більше 2000
вилікуваних російськими солдатами без жодної
відповідальність і давайте не будемо грати в
дуже небезпечні та брудні ігри, але
обидві сторони відповідальні ні, це не
ми, а росіяни атакують нас, це не ми,
а росіяни здійснюють агресію, тому ви
відкидаєте це звинувачення в правах людини,
ви відкидаєте себе спочатку, ви говорите, що це
так, ні, вони не відмовляються, ми
їх розслідуємо, і я просто не відкидаю, я
сказав, що ми різні, ми
співпрацюємо з міжнародним
агентством обох гуманних прав MST
international, ми відкриті для цього
розслідування, ми співпрацюємо з
ними, і це дуже добре  символ
дуже хороший знак європейської країни
людина полірування велике спасибі за
перебування в зоні конфлікту дякую so tha  нк
ти